Hey youtubers it's Charlie.
So it was just revealed that Game of Thrones
Season 5 just made some more major changes
to the books.
So I'm just going to explain what those are.
We've already seen some other changes to main
characters and cutting out big characters
all together.
It's not a big surprise, they did say Season
5 would deviate from the books even more than
Season 4 did.
Season 4 just cut out a few minor things and
added scenes that weren't in the books.
Hello any New People, if you're just finding
me for the first time I'm doing weekly Game
Of Thrones Bonus videos until it comes back.
Be sure to Subscribe to get everything.
I'm even giving away copies of World of Ice
and Fire, so I'll explain that at the end
of the video.
So
general
blanket spoiler warnings in
case
you
don't
want to
know
anything
about season 5.